hey guys mkbhd here back with another
high definition video review and today
we're going to be taking a live look at
the devotech
solar sound 2 bluetooth stereo speaker
system now i didn't do an unboxing of it
but i'll show you right now here
everything that comes in the speaker box
guys so here you go this is the usb
charger for the us adapter of course
this here is an audio cable so you can
still plug it in by a three and a half
millimeter audio cable audio jack and
this is a usb
audio uh sorry a usb charging cable so
this will go straight into here and that
end will plug into the speaker
now i did say this is called the solar
sound 2 and that's because you can also
charge these via solar power
i wouldn't always charge these via solar
but it's great because the battery life
lasts forever so you can see this is the
uh the case that it comes in says
davidtech industries has their little
logo here and we'll go ahead and unzip
this and show you guys everything else
about the speaker that you might need to
know
so like i said in the title as we take
the case out of here it is a stereo
speaker system so there's a speaker on
this side and speaker on this side
you can see at the top here this is the
solar panel so anytime you have light
above this right now this light is
charging uh this speaker will work if i
turn it on there's the power button to
actually do so you also have your line
out and you're blind in so if you don't
have a bluetooth compatible mp3 player
you can still plug something in
via this three and a half millimeter
audio cable and you'll be able to listen
to your zoom hd or whatever
mp3 player that doesn't have bluetooth
and there's also your usb in for
actually charging it via the wall
charger so i'm moving through things off
to the side so we can actually take a
better look at the speaker it's pretty
lightweight like i said if you do want
to put this on your desk you do have
four smaller
uh
what i call you know the feet that you
can put on the desk so you can actually
slide this around pretty easily it's not
gonna you know lose traction a little
bit it's got a little tackiness but like
i said these are these are the good feet
that are good to have
okay so here on the front you'll have
your very basic audio controls
underneath that logo you'll have your
fast forward or skip to next track or
you're skipped to the beginning of the
track you also have volume up and down
play pause and your on off switch so
like i said it has been charging during
the course of this review so i'll go
ahead and press this button here
and you can hear that it's actually
turned on and on the front you'll see
a little bit of lights going on and it
actually does work
so i don't really have any audio that is
royalty free for me to play for you guys
so i can tell you a little bit about the
audio quality without actually playing
music
and uh what i can say is that the audio
quality is not as bad as you would think
when you're playing stuff via bluetooth
of course it is not the very very
highest quality it's going to be a
decent bit rate and you're going to get
a pretty good highs not really a lot of
mids or lows but then again it is a
portable speaker so this is something
convenient say if you're going on a trip
with a team or just for a car ride or
something short like that this is
definitely going to be good for that so
i'll go ahead and turn this off by
pressing that power button again
and just like that speaker system is off
so you can see these three foot buttons
on the front here are actually flush
they don't have any depth to them that's
because they are touch sensitive so if
you do have this in a backpack or
something you're going to make sure you
want to leave it off so you don't start
pressing buttons and interacting with
the speaker in your backpack
i've noticed that the charging time on
this is actually that's decently
impressive via solar power it's going to
take about as long as a cell phone to
fully charge when you're using a wall
outlet however when you do use solar
power to charge it might take a full day
to actually you know sitting outside or
in a windowsill to actually charge from
dead zero percent to all the way up to
100 so i think that's really nice
otherwise the speaker system is just
really good and really nice for the
portability that you get with it again i
was able to plug my zoom hd into the
back of it and get pretty much perfect
sound
you don't hear all the lows that you
would get if you had a subwoofer or
something like that of course but you're
you're gonna get you know decent maybe
laptop sound quality obviously out of
two speakers you can see that there's
the air hole down here at the bottom for
what little the driver does move and
also the speaker itself and that's on
both sides
so this is about laptop sound audio
quality
and if you're willing to pay for it
you're definitely going to get what you
want you're not going to overpay if you
get this from devo tech so i'm going to
include a link in the description or the
down bar as they call it for you guys to
check this out
so this has been my review of the solar
sound 2 bluetooth speaker from devotech
i hope you guys enjoyed and until next
time i'll talk to you guys in the next
review video thanks for watching